five four three two one blast up happy
birthday happy birthday happy birthday
happy thank you it's a flat face
Gilbert's birthday how old are you now
28 28 you lost weight
thank you right yeah you gotta go back
fat you're gonna go back fat can't go
back fat I want to look like we just say
this right shut the [ __ ] up is that I'm
telling you now if you gained another 50
pounds you would work out 10 times more
no I know I did I gained weight when I
was fat no auditions yeah but you're
stronger now okay that's true all right
I don't want competition Stacy stay
whatever you're doing I don't want
competition yeah guys we got kalila who
I'm [ __ ] just on the [ __ ] brink of
I'm here I'm gonna spread your cheeks
whoa he calls ventriloquism Zwick
nothing to do with until equips it does
he just breaks lobby I say he froze my
cheeks apart in public and he makes my
butthole talk in public
yeah yeah oh my god um I love this guy
right here man yeah I love my favorite I
love his name - what is it JC KC KC here
man and we got you know what else we got
right here in the back of me who Barton
Fink man oh wow is that a Jew Jay yeah
don't see Jews I'm sorry dude you right
are you Jewish yeah this doer I didn't
know you were roommates with the
old-timey a writer from the 1940s yes my
roommate Yeah right here dude I love
your [ __ ] dude
excuse me okay and now we have a special
guest tonight and I'm gonna say
something right now okay I met him via
destiny I was playing with Eric Griffin
that black okay
my brother Stevie we be and all of us in
the sky was also sometimes involved he's
very good at destiny his name is Eric
Cooke he is also a UFC fighter so give
him a round of applause okay yeah now
you can talk now
yeah
you're the only guess who's actually
obeyed those rules yeah I'm coming into
somebody else's house you know whoa I
love these [ __ ] independence
everybody thinks fighters are like you
know some mean you know yeah just gonna
beat your ass all the time yeah no no
not at all very respectful I like the
way you guys I don't know how everyone
got together I don't know how'd you meet
so you met Eric Griffin first online
I met Griffin well what was crazy about
it was uh I followed him on Twitter
because I was always a workaholics fan I
don't know why but okay it's a wonderful
show full of comedy and delight but no I
followed him on Twitter and I saw him
like post make a post towards Bungie
talking about destiny uh-huh and I was
you know I I sent him a tweet and I was
like you know [ __ ] if you ever play you
want some help hit me up cuz I'm really
good at destiny yeah you're very good um
he's so good and he followed me but he
never hit me up and then you know the
app will companion app yeah yeah yeah
you erased all of it yeah
well gone let's get into that later okay
okay you call me Yoko Ono for dancing
but but then I went on there cuz I was
just looking to to finish a raid and I
was playing I was playing with you guys
for like four hours
I didn't know who the hell it was yeah
and then we started talking about like
what we do and [ __ ] like because I they
were talking about comedy yes yeah told
him I fought in the UFC and you know
he's like oh [ __ ] what's your name and
you know I asked and I didn't know his
name was Eric Griffin I knew him as
Montez yeah you know he's like oh [ __ ] I
follow you on twitter I was like you
know what's your name he's uh psych Eric
Griffin I'm like he's like Montez from
workaholics I was like whoa so that's
how crazy how small of a world that is
because how many people play destiny and
how many people are on this app like
yeah now finding that but I mean that
was we found each other yeah we found
you're very good at it he's be the best
one out of the group he has to fight by
far but I honestly believe that
the worst Griffin I think yeah Craig's
actually no we looked up Katie's today
Yahoo and Craig is terrible
I can imagine you want to bring his name
up because he's on the precipice of
suicide anyways he's doing great in life
oh is what I meant to say complete
opposite yeah yeah but don't worry the
filming we did we all sat on him like in
front of them yeah I like Craig a lot I
can't take it I like Craig a lot but uh
but no he's by far the worst he is I was
a second worst I think then it's Griff
yeah Griffin first okay who's better
Steve or Bobby Oh Bobby hasn't played in
so long when they were playing I pick a
side I don't know you don't remember
I don't know but Steve is better than
both those guys Stevie yeah Steve is
getting better and yeah but when I
talked to Eric on Saturday and I had him
rank everybody I said are you better
than Bobby he was like oh yeah
Bobby sucks and then you told me
differently he well maybe because he has
so much fat in his eyes right like you
know he's so fat his face then it went
into his eyes and he can't see clearly
enough because I'm gonna tell you this
right now he is not better than I am
he's in fact we do a group crucible I
was always lasted well I wanted to do I
wanted to do like not me obviously but
everybody else individual match to see
who's the best how do you feel how does
it feel to play with such shitty players
if you you know they're lucky they can
be funny and I like I just like to
relish them talking [ __ ] to everybody
each other yeah rarely do they ever try
to talk [ __ ] to me you know but they're
talking [ __ ] to each other I think it's
nice yeah because um we don't want our
heads to be crushed by your hand alright
so
[Music]